business leader political activist
philanthropist these are all
descriptions of meg Whitman
one of the most successful business
executives in the world today since 2011
she's been president CEO and our
chairman of Hewlett Packard and since
2015 she's been the CEO and president of
Hewlett Packard enterprise and chairman
of Hewlett Packard is chairman of HP Inc
Board of Directors as someone who knows
her from serving on that board at HP Inc
I can tell you no one just shows up and
becomes president CEO and chairman of
one of the world's most important
corporations in a business world
overwhelmingly run by men meg Whitman
has earned every accolade
and has repeatedly demonstrated the
benefit of pursuing new and unexpected
challenges having been an accomplished
high school student athlete Meg set her
sights on becoming a physician when she
enrolled at Princeton just a few years
after women were first admitted but a
summer spent selling magazine
advertising revealed magazine
advertising reveals her true calling
this drove her to pursue her bachelor's
degree in economics and then an MBA from
Harvard med spaz from there is meteoric
she joined Procter and Gamble where she
worked with Steve Case who later founded
AOL she took a position with Bain &
Company
where she rose to senior vice president
and along the way worked with Mitt
Romney who would later become governor
of Massachusetts and compete for the
presidency of the United States meg then
served as an executive with Disney
stride right FTD and Hasbro before
taking the helm of a fledgling company
that made her a household name auction
web is probably not the name you are
expecting but under 10 years of her
leadership meg whitman grew auction web
into a multibillion-dollar global
phenomenon now known as eBay that has
revolutionized the way humanity trades
goods not content to rest on our laurels
make started a charitable foundation
that has focused much of its giving and
addressing global warming and ecosystem
restoration
she's also dabbled in politics running
an historic campaign for governor of
California in 2010 in fact the New York
Times singled her out as one of the
women most likely to become the first
female president of the United States
since 2011 Megas worked tirelessly at
Hewlett Packard company and Hewlett
Packard Enterprise after their historic
split in 2015 I give you the person
Forbes magazine named the 20th most
powerful woman in the world Meg Whitman
well president cherche members of the
class of 2017 members of the faculty
distinguished guests fellow recipients
of honorary degrees families of the
graduating class ladies and gentlemen
it's a true honor to be with you today
and it's a great privilege to receive an
honorary Doctor of business practice
degree and I am grateful to be earning
my degree in a lot less time and with a
lot fewer all-nighters than it took many
of you to earn yours to the parents of
the graduating class of 2017
it is a magnificent and memorable day
when your child graduates from college
it certainly is a wonderful day for you
and I'm guessing that for many of you
parents it's a pretty good day for your
wallet as well congratulations for
having traveled this journey with your
children a journey that began not with
their enrollment at this university but
at the moment of their birth whether
your children fully realize it or not
whether they have fully expressed it to
you or not and they will they would not
be here today without your love and
support and encouragement along the way
so congratulations to the Paris
most important to the class of 2017
congratulations
graduating from college is an impressive
achievement but especially graduating
from one of the leading universities in
the world an institution characterized
by high standards and excellence one
that has produced winners of Nobel
Prizes and Turing Tony Emmy and Academy
Award winners carnegie mellon mellon
university has prepared you for a life
of purpose and meeting and there are
people and moments you will never forget
including I understand the Spring
Carnival which includes what I gather
are some pretty amazing amusement park
rides booths
and buggy races to bagpiping which the
school has made into an art form and to
my personal favorite the band without
pants a tradition unique to Carnegie
Mellon and I'm confident I can say one
you are unlikely to encounter in your
first full-time job you are graduating
at a moment of great challenge for our
nation when our country will decide on
matters having to do not with just
commerce but conscience not just what we
will with what we will gain but what we
will give not just with our military
power but with our deepest ideals this
is hardly the most difficult moment in
American history I believe you can
safely argue that the Civil War two
world wars and the Great Depression have
us beat by a longshot
you are a blessed generation in so many
ways
with opportunities unimaginable to pass
generations and gratitude is one of the
hallmarks of a fulfilled life but every
life has hardships every generation
faces obstacles
and we are in the midst of our
profoundly important moment in the
political and civil civic life of
America the challenges today are more
from within than without and I believe
this is a moment that if we do not
handle it well could produce harmful
effects on my generation and on yours
and on generations yet on board the
stakes are that serious so today I want
to speak about some disturbing trends in
our national life trends that need to be
challenged by people of both genders
every class race and ethnic ethnic
background of every political party and
ideology but most especially by young
people who are not only inheritors of
the future but will do so much to shape
it the first disturbing trend I want to
mention is the attack on truth there are
many people these days including people
at the highest level in public life
who use lies lies to de-fat devalue
truth those who are part of this effort
like describing what's happening
euphemistically using phrases like
alternative facts but we know better
to paraphrase Shakespeare to clarify
Shakespeare's Juliet a lie by any other
name is still a lie what is so striking
is the brazenness and rapidity of the
lies and their purpose which is to deal
Ajith Imai sources of information
hostile to those in power the lies
tumbled down like rocks in an avalanche
they are not subtle
they are overt obvious and part of a
conscious effort language is being
employed not to reveal reality but to
obscure it not to simply mislead people
but to disorient them to assert power
over truth in an effort to deconstruct
it so here's why this should matter to
you if we do not share a common reality
we can't reason together truth creates
restraints on power if we allow those
with power to control the very idea of
truth itself then we cannot identify and
stand against injustice and if we can't
identify injustice and we cannot replace
it with concepts like equality under law
respect decency compassion and justice
itself
a great university is always enlisted
against the spread of illusion and on
the side of reality said President
Kennedy and that is the essence of your
calling as graduates of a great
University my encouragement to you is to
be women and men who stand for truth who
spends your life in search of it even if
you never fully know it who believed in
inquiry in fact in objective reality and
who have the courage to speak truth to
power even when there may be a cost to
doing so if you do if you are defenders
of truth and an age more stylized
it will have a liberating effect on our
fellow citizens and make more possible
all good things in life a second truth
that needs to be confronted is the
attack on free speech in the last
several years we have seen a powerful
movement one that seeks to shut down
free speech gained traction in the
Academy the very institutions that were
created in order to allow for the free
exchange of ideas on some campuses we've
seen certain speakers not invited on
others they've been shouted down and on
still others we are witnessing violence
now I understand this kind of thing
isn't happening on most American
campuses but it's happening in too many
places and it needs to end but there's
something else going on as well college
students are increasingly demanding
protection from words and speech they
find offensive we hear a lot about
trigger warnings and safe spaces which
are designed to protect students from
viewpoints that they might find
upsetting and unsettling here's why I
think this is problematic for one thing
I don't think most of you want to be
treated like porcelain dolls
and now that you are college graduates
the rest of the world and certainly the
business world won't treat you that way
so no one is doing college students any
favors when they intellectually isolate
that but the issue extends beyond the
walls of the Academy and matters whether
or not you ever step foot on a campus
again for while many of you are about to
complete your formal education you will
spend a lifetime continuing to learn
gathering and processing new information
and dealing with people with different
life experiences and points of view
shutting down free speech insulating
ourselves from hearing competing points
of view is the equivalent of injecting
poison into the bloodstream of our
Republic John Stuart Mill in his 1859
classic on Liberty put it as well as
anyone ever has and I quote he who knows
only his own side of the case knows
little of that mill wrote his reason may
be good and no one may have been able to
refute them but he is equally unable to
refute the reasons on the opposite side
if he does not so much as know what they
are he has no ground for preferring
either opinion mill went on to say this
nor is it enough that he should hear the
opinions of adversaries from his own
teachers presented as they state them
and accompanied by what they offer as
reputations he must be able to hear from
persons who actually believe them he
must know them in their most plausible
and persuasive form so my encouragement
to you is to be the men and women who
stand up for free speech who welcomes
debate who model for others what genuine
dialogue is and who are not afraid
to have your beliefs challenged too many
of us live in intellectual silos where
we seek out people and information that
simply reinforces our existing opinions
venture out of those silos we are better
when we are exposed to different ideas
and competing philosophies learn to
listen in order to understand others not
just to respond to them and remain open
to the possibility that you may may have
something to learn from others be the
generation that embodies real tolerance
genuine inquiries and authentic
open-mindedness it is what this nation
desperately needs during this fractured
and fractious time
the third trend that needs to be
confronted is the attack on civility we
live in an age of escalating incivility
we see it all around us on our roads in
airwaves in sports stadiums and on
social media and in politics the problem
has gotten worse recently with those
running for high public office
mocking reporters and demeaning
opponents with childish names or worse
it seems that no words no matter how
hurtful or cruel to others are
considered inappropriate we are
fostering the conditions in which we
view others not as opponents but enemies
we're treating one another as subhuman
and that's a terribly dangerous line to
cross civility is more than nice manners
it's a precondition of democratic
dialogue in the words of Professor
Stephen L Carter of Yale Law School
civility is part of the quote etiquette
of democracy unquote it allows for
genuine social interaction it's been
said that the true genius of Martin
Luther King jr. was not his ability to
argue the pain of an oppressed people
but his ability to inspire those very
people to be loving and civil in their
dissent we should treat each other with
civility not because we agree with
others but because it is a measure of
our respect for human dignity it's what
we owe all people including those with
whom we have fierce disagreements our
institutions our culture our communities
cannot be sustained let alone thrive if
civility is eroded it is an essential
democratic virtue
kingman brewster a former president of
Yale said quote the presumption of
innocence is not just a legal concept in
commonplace terms it rests on the
generosity of spirit which assumes the
best not the worst of a stranger so my
encouragement to you is to be the women
and men who embody civility who
demonstrate a generosity of spirit in an
ungenerous time and who assume the best
not the worst of the stranger of those
you do not know people whose life
experiences are different than yours and
who may see the world in a dramatically
different way than you do in doing so
you will make us a more decent and just
society this country desperately needs
the skills you have developed during
your years at Carnegie Mellon but it
needs something more than your skills it
needs your ideals you leave this great
University as better men and women than
when you arrived more knowledgeable and
better educated I'm sure but I trust
wiser and more hopeful there's a
beautiful line by William Wordsworth in
his poem the prelude in which he says
quote what we have loved others will
love and we will teach them how the
faculty at CMU has taught you what to
know and love and now it is your turn
to teach others what you have come to
know and love I wish you all a joy a
life of joy and purpose of success and
fulfillment and congratulations to the
great class of 2017 thank you very much
meg thank you for your thoughtful and
sobering remarks you're not only we're
not only inspired by your words but also
motivated by your example it's been an
honor to have you as our keynote speaker
thank you again meg please join me once
again in thanking Meg Baker
[Applause]